hallo daniel hallo tina
gehen wir heute zusammen aus
in ein restaurant und danach in die
disco
ich kann heute abend nicht mit ihr
ausgehen
ich bin krank
dass du nicht kommen kannst was hast du
denn
ich weiß es nicht ich glaube dass sich
die grippe habe man darf ich fußball
spielen gehen
[Musik]
hast du deine hausaufgaben schon gemacht
nein ich mache sie später jetzt scheint
die sonne und meine freunde wollen
fußball spielen
nein michael du darfst nicht fußball
spielen
letzte woche hast du eine schlechte note
in der schule
du musst die hausaufgaben machen und
mehr lernen
andreas möchtest du ein stück kuchen
nein danke ich habe diabetes ich soll
keinen kuchen essen
alles mit zucker soll ich vermeiden hat
mein arzt gesagt
sarah hier darf man nicht rauchen
rothschild nicht gesehen
nein entschuldigung ich mache meine
zigarette aus hallo hallo schatz ich
komme später nach hause ich muss heute
länger im büro bleiben wir haben sehr
viel arbeit
schon wieder das sagst du jeden tag
ich kann es nicht ändern ich muss heute
länger im büro bleiben wenn ich nicht
fertig werde entlässt mich mein chef
kommst du auch noch ins café claudio
nein ich kann leider nicht ich muss noch
arbeiten
und du kommst du mit
nein ich kann auch nicht ich habe einen
termin beim zahnarzt
ja
marco trinken wir einen kaffee zusammen
das geht leider nicht ich gehe jetzt in
den supermarkt
dann kommen heute zum abendessen
der etwas für sie kochen
aber du eric
ich muss leider passen das nächste mal
komme ich gern
nach der schule ins fitnesstraining ich
brauche ein bisschen bewegung
na gut dann gehe ich halt allein ins
café
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video